back here in southern nevada it's been
nearly a year since the historic mount
charleston lodge burned down but the
good news here is that plans to rebuild
are finally coming together candace
charles joining us from mount charleston
with what we know so far and candace
they're doing a really good job of
trying to get people still up to the
mountain with some fun events coming up
this weekend
they are and they're actually not too
expensive i got to say you guys it is
absolutely beautiful out here now mount
the charleston lodge still has a lot of
work ahead but the good news is we're
hearing that folks can start going back
up there sooner rather than later now
the ellis family who owns the lodge
tells me they are currently putting
together the plans to rebuild and it
will be better than ever right now
they're offering a weekend pop-up event
at the site called pine dining each
weekend a local chef takes over the
mountain for a private dining experience
so we wanted to create something where
people would have an opportunity to go
up to the space and experience it in
this downtime when we are you know in
between planning and beginning to
rebuild the new lodge
now tickets for pine dining are 95 for
saturday's cookout session and 195 for
the chef's table all proceeds go to the
charity of choice the chef's charity of
choice and again they're working on
finalizing these plans to rebuild i hear
there's going to be a special
announcement coming up soon so stick
with us right here on air online and on
social for the linux for now kyle canyon
at the base of mount charleston i'm
candice charles 8 news now